hey what's up guys welcome to another
episode of get close I'm your co-host
Geo and I'm Bart
and Bart you've been getting on my
goddamn nerves I have yes I'm so sorry
what's going on
well I am towards my last couple of
weeks of my bodybuilding prep
and uh it's been pretty hard and
everyone tells me that towards the end
you get like really hangry you get
grumpy you get very irritable because
there is a portion of maybe like the
last three or four weeks before another
depletion phase where your fats get
dropped to like almost nothing and if
you know anything about like science or
biology or how hormones work all
hormones including testosterone estrogen
or your feel good love like all of those
hormones run off of fats they're
actually fat derivatives so the minute
you dump your fats you almost
instantaneously feel like [__] and then
all your hormones AKA your emotions are
out of whack so I'm sorry if I've been
irritable towards you or grumpy or
anything like that yeah so walk me
through
um the whole phase of this like why you
started uh what it's like things you've
learned along the way so let's start
with that so I'll start with what I've
been saying for maybe
maybe 20 years I started lifting when I
was that you're hungry
I've been saying I've been hungry for 20
years yeah oh [__] always
you're like I'm hungry I can't make
decisions right now can you just decide
or can you just drive for me I'm too
hungry so that's why it's like so gnarly
for me to see you go down this path
because like literally you will say I'm
so hungry to the point I can't even
drive it's not my fault that I'm an
alpha organism
but what I've read is a lot of organisms
like complain like [__] all the time
well it's just because we learned words
as humans oh I see because in the jungle
it would just be like grab someone by
the neck and then throw them like kind
of like how scar is you know in Lion
King you just grab them by the neck go
get me food but now we're human beings
and we gotta talk and stuff but like an
alpha would just beat the [__] out of
someone make them go through something I
see and I can't do that because we live
in America but maybe in like other
countries like Korea we would be able to
if that's what you want to live and
that's fine with me
but uh make sure they don't do that in
Korea maybe North Korea maybe North
Korea
um I'm sure the deducted guys in North
Korea too but um yeah like before I met
you though you've actually never met me
at my biggest
are you sure about that
are you sure so you do know my about my
lifting career right like freshman year
sophomore year high school I was still
sub 100.
so um when I started lifting I was sub
100 and in order to bulk I would eat an
insane amount every day at least two by
uh two four by fours from in and out at
least one big ass breakfast burrito you
know that thing's packed with like eggs
cheese potatoes and the tortilla I was
probably consuming like a good 10 000
calories every single day just trying to
like put on mass put on strength the
average person's supposed to consume
like how much I know there's it's hard
to say an average but I would say the
average average is probably like 2200
calories okay so that is gnarly so in a
whole day yeah so if you're consuming 10
000 the average person is about 2200
that is [__] insane I'm doing four to
five x of what they're eating prior to
you trying to pack on so much weight
right because you were sub 100s did you
have the same appetite was it just a
fast metabolism no or was it I I eat
like taika uh you know how like Thai
Cuts like he barely eats and even if the
food's bomb you're like oh he's gonna
devour this and he still only eats like
half or three quarters yeah I ate like a
burger so wait every time you blame that
on my side where you're like oh you eat
like your mom blue that actually comes
from you too because we both didn't like
eating yeah but that's not fun who likes
to blame themselves all right you [__]
go yeah so um I would eat pretty much
like in one meal I would eat 2x what
everyone eats the whole day to catch up
and put on muscle and size and you want
to be in a caloric Surplus yeah to build
right and so I kept doing that until I
hit my I would say maybe even an average
weight of 130 ish this is still within
the same year same High School uh same
high school I categorize my lifting
career not by years but by phases in my
life okay so this space is what so this
is high school so from high school I
bulked from like one 03 all the way up
to
170 when I graduated high school yeah in
like three years is this muscle and fat
or just fat or you were just looked
normal now like what's your height too I
would say to the to a third party they
probably go oh yeah Bart looks fit
really even on 10 000 calories
because you were doing just weight
lifting like just benching mainly
bodybuilding weight training and
wrestling
oh the wrestling guy yeah so I think
because I had like
um you know you have high test because
you're in puberty yeah
um high intensity yeah because of
wrestling so I think um my body the
perfect recipe yeah my body was able to
kind of like be in a lean mass space
yeah even though it was all garbage yeah
even though I was eating garbage and it
was like extremely high fat so I was
able to go into this like lean mass face
yeah and um so I got there and then but
now my regular dietary habits are my
dietary habits they became your new
habits yeah so it's not a linear growth
right like you can't pack on muscle from
100 pounds to 500 and be ripped at 500
so I hit about 170 uh at 170 I went to
boot camp I came back out back down to
130 because you're completely you know
like you're depleted you're depleted
sleep deprived doing a lot of cardio
high stress probably running like 10
miles a day
um you're barely eating anything barely
eating yeah it's very regimented you're
not sleeping so I come out 1 30. the
minute I come out and you go to MLS
school which is like the school that you
go learn you know your job and stuff at
that's normal Marine Corps now and in
normal Marine Corps you don't have like
wake up at four and do all this crazy
stuff now it's more like wake up at six
and then you have to go to the chow hall
and have the child you can eat whatever
you want and the child is like HomeTown
Buffet it's actually really really good
what HomeTown Buffet okay really really
good not a thing if you were like oh if
it's like I don't know what's a really
good Buffet that's not Vegas is there a
good one I think the best ones are in
Vegas okay well yeah there's no such
thing as good Buffet that's not a Vegas
Golden Corral really to me all buffets
so the reason what makes Buffet so good
is if you want something it's unlimited
too you can make them do whatever
so that to me is like huh oh for me it's
if the food's good or not so like for
example I'd follow my favorite
bodybuilders of the time Ronnie Coleman
Marcus rule Jay Cutler all those guys
and I would see how many eggs they have
to eat every morning like 10 to 20 eggs
right and it's boring they would eat it
raw too remember that some of them would
eat a raw so I'm like okay I gotta eat
10 to 20 eggs every morning and because
you're at like a HomeTown Buffet type
place I can go can you make me a 10 egg
omelet and they'll do it you know bell
peppers mushrooms whatever can you do 10
egg scrambled can I do 10 uh over easy
so because they I was able to get it
customized like I couldn't wait to eat
breakfast at the child Hall every
morning because I could have my eggs
done however I want and there's by this
point are you still having to like force
yourself to eat this ton of food now
your appetite's open it's I mean it's
definitely more open it's now open so
this is this is uh a comparison okay I
remember in second grade vividly
um I went to a private school for a
little bit and I think on certain days
you get to have like
um actual like catered franchise food so
it's huge it's not cafeteria food so for
example Big Macs uh McDonald's I
remember a second grader almost all my
friends finished their entire Big Mac
you guys would eat Big Macs they
wouldn't give you happy meals no
everyone got a Big Mac as a second
grader yeah I don't know why everyone
had a Big Mac
majority of my friends all finished a
Big Mac and their fries and their drink
and I could barely eat half a Big Mac
for a second grader is massive all my
friends ate it wow and then so um that
was my gauge I was like oh if this is a
designated meal for a human I eat less
than a designated human and then so now
after boot camp
um I think I eat normal I can eat a
whole big mac and I'm like oh I'm very
very content but to grow I was like
doubling it no you know like two Big
Macs two fries two drinks you could
still consume all that without throwing
up or was it like really hard
it's really hard but one of the uh most
influential guys I don't even know his
name but he was this huge bodybuilder at
the Bally's that I used to train at in
Rosemead yeah he would tell me in high
school he'd be like oh my God how do you
get so big he goes if you're not stuffed
you're wrong and I was like what do you
mean he goes you should feel like you're
throwing up all the time oh God so he
was like he's like this he goes this is
when you're okay right this is when
you're hungry this is when you're full
this is when you want to throw up you
want to stay in this top margin you
don't if you're going down to I'm okay
your body is already breaking stuff down
you want to be in full to stuff always
as soon as you feel full go back to
stuff so because of that I just got into
this habit of just chowing challenge you
know wouldn't you know to stop where you
were like okay I need to pull back now
I've achieved size or is it just when
your gut is like covering your dick now
and you're like oh [__] I went too far
well that's when you start having like
body dysmorphia where I had it on the
other side I would just keep pounding
food right and then I'm one of those
guys that's kind of blessed where like
even when I'm like high body fat
percentage you kind of still see ABS
yeah so in my brain I still thought I
was lean and then I got all the way up
to like 220 or 230. that was the fattest
you ever met the fattest I ever was you
haven't even met me yet
yeah so you've never been 220 with me I
have but that was actually leaner than
before
because the 220 you meant I still did
cardio and all that and I still did
cardio and stuff I have pictures of you
and it's intense and trust me I was
fatter before and I remember vividly
because of a wake-up call so I was 220
230 and um I remember that I was getting
ready to go to Thailand with the Marine
Corps and Thailand I've never heard that
I didn't go to Thailand I was getting
ready to go to Thailand and so every
time you you have to go certain places
certain countries some places you have
to get a whole array of shots I don't
know why maybe there's crazy bacteria
viruses or whatever that do blood work
and all that so I remember that was also
how timed out to be at the same time as
my Marine physical oh you're too do any
uh no not physical like a physical
denomination yes I know that but at that
time you're 220. yeah I was big I was
big as [__] I know I was strong I
already know what the results were and
at this time I felt so good because the
gym was my kind of like stage my
playground you know even though I wasn't
performing to anybody but I remember
vividly being at this point you know
seated military press I remember hitting
two plates for ten and I was like that's
gnarly full this is my till this day I
don't know if I've ever repeated that
but there's just certain PRS in my head
that I'm like [__] yeah like my
lifestyle is conducive to
massive strength I remember doing shrugs
with like seven plates for like five or
six you know like what did you do
tells you to one to have massive
strength I think growing up I've always
been the smallest weakest kid in class
so the minute I realized your physique
and your capability is in your hands I
was like I want to push this
you know okay so yeah um
I uh you had to take physicals you got
my physical and in my mind you know when
you're that strong and you're able to do
all these things yeah you think you're
at your Peak physical and when you got
there on your own like I wasn't like a
couch potato you know like that just
accumulated right it was it was
intentional exactly
I got my my blood work done and my I had
crazy high cholesterol obviously yeah
crazy high cholesterol and that was like
a shocker I was like what the [__] I'm
like I'm like 20 years old 21 I'm like I
have crazy high cholesterol the other
thing is my BMI was super awesome in the
Marine Corps they have these things
called regs which are regulations if you
want to get promoted you can't be a fat
piece of [__] and then so they saw this
they're like if your promotion comes up
and this is still your BMI you're not
gonna get it did these people know you
were stronger they were just like this
dude's fat
well the Marine Corps doesn't really
matter they just go based off of like a
standardized BMI that's funny so you're
like but I'm [__] I could do two
plates yeah but they also and then the
other part is I remember uh my best
three mile time at that time was maybe
like 19 19 30. and it was uh and even
when I don't train my worst but I run
balls to the wall I could still hit a
24. and that was to me being a [__] bag
at this time I barely made the cut at
like 28.
I think at 30. that's slow as [__] at
30. I think you technically failed your
PFT
so if you're running a 10 minute mile
for three miles and that's your Sprint
you technically failed it so I remember
hitting a 28 going uh oh like I'm not
going to get promoted and this is so bad
and my cholesterol and everything so
that's when I went
like that and I started dieting hard and
I uh started uh running four miles three
times a week this is now you at UCLA
right and this is about the time when
you met me when I was about probably
like 180 190s yeah I started like
bringing it back down okay
so then this is the beginning of your
career now we're kind of going into that
so I'm just saying that that that was
actually the fattest time that you have
never met me but that was the fattest
time in my
in my this whole lifting career where I
had a huge wake-up call and I'm like
okay that is what I never want to be
ever again okay
so fast forward to today um why am I
doing bodybuilding
um for a couple of reasons I think for
the last two decades I've always told
myself because I've studied bodybuilders
right like back in the day you power
lifters weren't really getting light
shine on them like CrossFit they barely
are now yeah crossfitters wasn't really
a thing like Fitness wasn't mainstream
the way it is now now you go to Banana
Republic there's a fitness section
J.Crew there's a fitness section Lacoste
makes Fitness close right back then it's
like everyone's wearing brands that no
one even heard of like house of pain and
[__] like that or old PE clothes it's
such an underground culture
and
um but I studied it so much and I knew
their diets and I knew how disciplined
that they had to be that I was just like
you know what that's not really me I
think I'm more of a strength athlete I
like power movements so I was like and
why did you think it wasn't you how did
you view it that you were like that's
not me I just didn't have that kind of
discipline you know so it was mainly the
discipline that you were like I don't
have that [__] yeah I was like I can eat
I cannot eat I cannot not eat what's the
discipline part that you feel that you
lacked that was necessary for
bodybuilding at that time
um so like at that time the way that
everyone trained was pretty much like
unanimous I mean it's still very close
to it like once you get close to prep
but everyone had like eight to ten meals
lined up and it's very simple it's the
tried and true chicken broccoli you know
tilapia asparagus like high protein low
fat high protein low fat nutrient timing
um all right exactly at the certain time
right wake up exactly at the service
because back then they believed that
you're not supposed to eat carbs
fluid count you know I'm only eating
like a
um like let's say if your fluids are two
gallons a day if you made something with
it you count that liquid from your two
gallon like it's very very it's a
science you're a lab rat pretty much
yeah and I was like dude like I love
indulging I mean you know right like
every time we're dating and stuff it's
like oh let's get some french toast
there's some waffles like I like to go
off the rails pretty often and so just
knowing how stringent you have to be
with bodybuilding you you didn't have
that I just knew I didn't have that nor
did I think it was going to be fun for
me
you know like some people don't ever do
something like there's there's straight
up couch potatoes to marathon runners
like night and day they're like I don't
do that but I actually think that will
be fun I just never I've never tried it
but I just feel like I should do it me
studying it that much I was like I don't
think I would ever want to do this so
it's mainly the diet
mainly the diet because training I love
training I love training in all aspects
bodybuilding probably looking CrossFit
whatever I like training I like all
modes of training it's the diet and then
the the adherence to some sort of like
extreme schedule that was like [__]
that's gonna be really hard I don't know
if I can do that
oh so you didn't like that part of it
the schedule part of it the dietary
schedule I see okay okay I thought you
meant in the training no no the dietary
schedule I did not like that part of it
at all okay and I'm a very like like if
there's two car guys right there's like
car show guys and then there's like
track guys I've always felt like I'm
more of a track guy so even when it came
to lifting I saw like bodybuilding as
more show based right well because it is
right like everything detailed to the to
the max yeah brake calipers are clean
you clay bar the car you know and then
and then you have not so much about the
performance it's more so about like all
the polishes and like the high quality
stuff on the outside yeah and then the
track car you don't you might not even
need it inside is [__] up yeah but the
inside's a thousand horsepower I've
always been and those two have always
been on this side so I think when it
came to like bodybuilding or
powerlifting I just went straight to
power lifting too because it just felt
much more who I was yeah so yeah those
are the main reasons why like I've
always told myself for like you know
because the people like throughout
Fitness all my friends that I started
meeting in the space Mark Bell the
Baileys all of them they're like dude
you should do a bodybuilding show for
sure and I'm just like I don't know I
don't know if that's me I don't know if
I can stick to it that's too much
commitment
and uh I think what really made me go
like
I should probably do it is this year is
barbell brigade's 10-year anniversary
and although it's its own brand it's
Genesis started with us with me
and um I think the last five years
yeah probably the last five years you
know I've been trying to write my wrongs
right like any regret that I have like
military I feel like I didn't get this
much out of military I'll take my own
tactical classes
um I felt like I've always used Asthma
as a crutch
um run a marathon I felt like I didn't
get the most out of wrestling my mind
wasn't in the right place I was teaching
school going to Raves do Jiu Jitsu so
I've been in this like
this like the last five years I've been
just like right my wrongs type of
mindset and then I've always felt like
all the things I swept under the rug
there's one really big pile in the
corner the biggest pile in the corner is
bodybuilding because I know it's a 24 7
lifestyle it's not just a sport it's a
24 7 like entire lifestyle
that I was like [__] I've never as a
fitness professional as what why why
would a lot of people would consider me
I'm like I've never even been under 10
body fat and I probably should so that's
when I decided to go you know what 2023
will be the year that I signed up for my
first bodybuilding show
and when you were doing that were you
like yeah it's time I gotta do it or
were you still pretty reluctant
um I think I had a lot of momentum going
into it because it actually started with
get lean with you because through covet
both of us put on like 20 30 pounds
right and
um we got we we lost a lot of weight
that was really I didn't put on 20 30
pounds during covid how much did you put
on
uh it was in Turin kovid during covet I
was nice that was fine yeah yeah because
I remember after covid we had to we had
a whole freezer full of food so we
decided to start uh waste yeah mainly
you okay so I gained 30 pounds I didn't
gain 30 pounds during cold but I was
nice during covert post covet the the
freezer the freezer era yeah I gained 30
pounds I just had the baby weight still
oh I see excuse me which was probably
like 10 pounds I see yeah I've never
been 20 30 over oh okay well anyways we
did the get lean and we both got in
pretty good shape which is pretty cool
and then um I I think having that
momentum I wrote that into the next
thing which is get strong so I trained
for a powerlifting me and well actually
before that yeah that was last year too
well actually get strong in between get
strong and Hitler and I had another goal
in the middle I don't know if you
remember I've never squad or 500.
remember that's always been my
powerlifting goal and so I think after
get lean
um I was like I got a squat 500 I just
gotta like write all my wrongs and end
up squatting 515 and I was like [__]
yeah like I was very very happy that's
15 pounds more than I I even wanted and
then I was like okay cool and your
weight was still pretty good that one
got a little bit heavier because then I
think was right around Christmas time so
I put on a little bit of weight but not
like before and then I'm like okay cool
I have a little bit of momentum
now I'm squatting I'm consistently
squatting 470 490 at sub 200 let's do me
so it did get strong that whole series
and then that gave me some momentum and
then now I'm doing the stud muffins
bodybuilding show with JP and it's just
kind of been like this constant momentum
and uh
it's it I think it really like drove me
to like kind of not get off the horse
you know like once you get off the horse
and you feel how good like half time
could be sometimes it's hard to get back
on the court yeah especially if you
don't have a strong wide like to get
back in it yeah but now but the whole
last year I felt like I've just been on
a train
and just like [__] kept going and it
felt it's it's been really really good
cool I'm glad you say that because
um yes big picture obviously it's good
right because you're like you're like
tweaking all of your internal dials and
like the athlete and use getting
fine-tuned and like
getting in Tip-Top shape but that's not
the reality of every day right like
every day when you start zooming into
the micro
um you're more like ah this is so
[__] hard or like damn it like life
happens right like uh we get a new dog
so now the sleeping gets [__] up
um The Barking now so now it's like you
still have to get up to achieve these
goals but now you're just exhausted and
this is a span of like maybe a whole
week where you're like completely sleep
deprived and now you have to like track
macros and now you're like traveling and
like what has that been like right
because again Grand schema things
[__] epic yeah it's dope you're on
this train choo choo that's what you
called it right yeah but like the
day-to-day the day-to-day is tough as
[__]
um I don't know if you've ever been on
like a 15 or 20 mile hike but like
there's a point where you start with
your friends right and it's fun oh we're
in Yosemite it's very novelty based and
you're happy and you're talking
um I would say that's probably like the
first month first month I get my first
drop in calories and it's tough but then
you get this reward of being extremely
disciplined so I think I was at like 16
1700 calories
um it's tough and you know all the stuff
I've been eating I couldn't really eat
anymore like even before it would get
strong I competed at 181 so I still have
to diet but it was more like macro based
diets where it's like I can adjust you
know have way more adjustment I can have
my fats at around 70 or something like
that when I got my 1600 calorie diet it
was like immediate boom you're down to
50. so now it's not the amount of play I
have it just got so narrow yeah like on
get strong for example like some of my
cheat codes is getting pizza at CPK I
can't get pizza anywhere else I can get
it at CPK because they have uh their
Hawaiian pizza is actually pretty low in
fat it's only 25 grams of fat one it's
uh it's cauliflower crust too you can
get the cauliflower crust so there's
like there's a cheat codes out there
that you can look for
so get strong while still getting lean
but there's cheat codes with this one
there is no cheat code like I have I
have not had CPK in three months I just
can't even afford 25 grams of fat
because that's literally like more than
half of what I have daily
so I would say the first month is
[__] novelty it's cool you're you're
you're making the Tupperware as a meal
prep you feel good about yourself you
announce it to your friends you know
then the second month I would say that's
when the hard part kind of starts
because that's when you're faced with
like the daily life and the novelty
wears off like what you're saying so for
example that's when if I eat my dinner
at six or seven I'm starving by nine and
I could barely sleep now in the morning
I wake up is it really starving
it's
um
are you starving now it's enough to wake
up at least once at night from Hunger
paints oh [__] so it's I mean now I wake
up by six times at night back then it's
at least one time already so I wake up
I'm like oh [__] or my stomach will
groan and actually make a loud noise I'm
like oh [__] you know
um
so that second month that part's tough
so your sleep is already not so good you
wake up
um
you're you're kind of like you can feel
your body starting to deplete and get
rid of all the stuff so you don't feel
like waking up like take on the day you
you wake up feeling like a little bit
weaker than you were yesterday do you
think this is a mental state too
like let's say we were doing it together
I think we'd feel it together oh so it's
not gonna make it better no okay yeah I
think it would feel it together because
I feel like it's a biological thing okay
and I can and I can almost and the
reason why I can anecdotally prove this
it's not scientifically prove this
because
um I've been training for 20 years right
I [__] love training it's one of my
favorite things to do and it's one of my
favorite things to do to actually pound
caffeine train my [__] ass off and I
feel like I start my day with cocaine
like I start my day on a high I can take
on anything
this last week or two this is like third
month fourth month now is the first time
I don't even want to train
so I've never actually felt this in the
20 years I've ever lifted oh my God now
you know what I feel like really yeah
you're like a normal person you don't
ever want to train no I mean I do it
like I I do it because I'm like I'll
have either a goal that I'm trying to go
for but it's never been in me to be like
yes I gotta get it done it's always uh
what's your favorite thing to do every
day uh I'm not a morning person no
everything anything what's your favorite
thing to do any time of the day every
day oh my God right now it's just do
nothing okay so imagine you're not able
to do nothing now yeah you don't even
want to do nothing that's how that's
what it feels like like I start my day
with taking a bump of cocaine imagine a
Coke addict going I don't even want
cocaine anymore yeah that's huge that's
like it was like that so I'm not there
yet but in the middle of the face I
started to feel that that's why I was
saying like it doesn't really matter if
you did it with me because you could
just feel your body every day feel
weaker and have less will and it just
feels like the slow Suffocation which it
literally is a slow Suffocation yeah
you're you're starving yourself yeah so
the only way I can get my mind off of it
is to train so I would train find an
excuse to train find an excuse to walk a
little bit more because if I can just
get moving I don't think about how
hungry and how depleted I am starting to
get and then comes like the daily life
and this is when I had like probably
like the biggest
um kind of like Epiphany or
or realization actually is on my damn I
shout outs to all the bodybuilders that
have kids because you know the minute
when you're an athlete and you focus on
yourself it's not that hard I think
because you don't have other
responsibilities but if you have other
kids other responsibilities you have
that right like I still gotta help Tyco
like get ready or do whatever like you
can't just focus on your thing and then
when that [__] eats snacks all
goddamn day you can't just go okay prep
mode clear out the pantry you know it's
like you you have to find a way to
coexist in a normal house that's still
eating yummies having a good time some
people want to sleep late some people
want to get breakfast in the morning
like
um you have to find a way to like
integrate yourself into that and so that
was kind of like uh
I was like
a kind of a tough struggle to kind of
figure out because you're inundated with
all these like you can't just go
like if you're by yourself you're the
odd one out at this point exactly like
the coach a usual coach can hit you with
the plan and you go got it you know and
you're like well actually I can't
because my kid doesn't gets out of
school here so I can't really eat here
and he has Jiu Jitsu here so you want me
to eat here but I can't really eat here
so I have to wait until he is ready to
eat but then by that time I'm starving
so I guess I'll eat here but then I have
to put him to bed but then I haven't ate
again and so now I'm starving again so
now you're kind of like whatever the
plan that your coach gives you you kind
of have to like Frankenstein away to
like make it work make it work you know
if it's like a regular person can just
go you remember those six pack bags
those old school bags where you just
stuff with six Tupperware you just go to
work and you just know every two hours
you pop one open right yeah well because
you're technically just taking care of
yourself exactly but the minute you have
a kid you have other stuff and you know
my mom's here just like things that get
integrated you kind of have to find ways
to like
um and that becomes kind of more of an
obstacle it's a little bit more
difficult but we still got it done
yeah
um
yeah I I've seen such a big change in
you like in your personality and it is
because
you're exhausted you don't have fuel you
can see me fuel energy it's a sense of
change in Personality yeah you're so
down like you're down like yeah it's
just your whole energy your whole mood
everything you're just it looks like
you're Clinging On To Life like just the
vibe is just
you know like it's just a sad sad yeah
one of my friends asked me he was like
how do you feel now
and I would say like the last three or
four weeks is its own phase
I feel like the first three or four
weeks novelty face feels good I'm going
to Bible building show I want to tell
everybody second wave for kind of
dealing with it and you're still okay
because like you're like I even make a I
was making a joke right you're like they
can I have a bike guy yeah yeah so
you're still trying to have a bike
you're still kind of connected with us
yeah yeah you're like on your own Island
but like there's still things that
connect us yeah whereas right now you're
literally by yourself when did you when
did this phase start
um
maybe like a couple weeks ago one week
or two weeks I don't know it feels like
it's been forever but maybe more so a
couple weeks now because it's like you
can't have maybe even three weeks like
you can't have anything we're having
like you don't even eat with us anymore
like this recent week you have to eat
later so it's just like an eye eating
dinner like for Lake Tahoe did you feel
that already Yes 100 that's how we left
early I see I see
um yeah it was it's just we our
lifestyles are just so off because I
consider Lake Tahoe the integration
phase still
yeah well no that's why we left early
yeah because it's just so like so I felt
down there already
um
not down not as down as you are now but
definitely different like we're not on
the same page we're not a unit
you know it felt very um like I'm just
the supporting person here like trying
to help you I see
that's not bad but um
uh yeah I just started feeling bad for
you going like why like I know what your
goal is and it's such a short term goal
um or for this specific thing because
the short-term goal is the show that I'm
like yeah why would why would we like
why put you yourself through this like
let's just focus on that and then we'll
get back to our version of normalcy once
the show's over yeah but yeah it's been
a you're just a different
you're just on an island by yourself
yeah I definitely feel it like the last
three weeks I remember one of my friends
asking me like how do you feel
and I was like honestly
like my will to survive is very low damn
yeah do you think this has also anything
to do with load test
for sure like if you were on steroids
because I'm a natural bodybuilder yes
your natural bodybuilder do you think
that would play anything into it because
I know there's a bunch of little tactics
that people will do right like one of
them being like black coffee the other
one some people take Adderall like
they're just different things that
people do to kind of fill in the gaps uh
so that they can live as much of a
normal routine
you know when they're during their prep
weeks or the final prep weeks it's hard
to say
because I've never been on steroids that
is hard to say but what I can say is
what I think I think it's actually
relative to your league
that's what I think so for so for
example like
um when you're natural right if you can
get down to seven percent body fat
like you're probably knocking on death's
door and it's very hard but that's gonna
get you to turn pro and also this though
might be what you're feeling now because
it's your first run at it maybe but let
me finish my point
a bodybuilder on steroids getting down
to seven percent is still technically
fat
he's trying to or she's trying to get
down to like or actually he he's trying
to get down to like five percent oh so
that's what I'm saying it might be
relative you know like a guy that's on
gear
um getting down to seven might not have
that big of a impact impact but that's
fat still so he needs to get down to
like five percent maybe three percent so
it might be relative where yeah it's the
same it's the same kind of struggle and
same journey and yes they have other
like dials they can turn for me it's
literally only cardio and then only my
food those two are is what's going to
dictate how much weight I lose how lean
I get for them they have a third factor
and that third factor is huge because
they can bump test which increases
muscle there's also other steroids that
dry you out there's diuretics there's
like all kinds of things that you can do
that you can adjust so I don't know I
actually
um don't really know but my gut feeling
is it's probably relative because I've
seen bodybuilders on steroids
uh in their depletion week and they're
pretty [__] as well yeah how do you
feel now
this is the worst I've ever felt right
now is this last week because uh this is
the depletion phase is like
the last the second to last week almost
where you're really bumped down so I
went from my 1600 calories down to like
1400 calories in the depletion week I
was down to 1200 calories and then 1200
calories it's specifically keeping my
fats under 30. and 30 is like the
biological amount of grams that you can
have to still function normally under
you go into 30 I'll probably have my
hair start falling out my nails start
getting brittle my eyes might start
getting dry I probably have like Ed like
there's like all kinds like a whole
[__] plethora of things that'll
probably start happening so I was there
for a six day depletion today is the
best that I have ever felt because my
nutrition just changed so today uh my
coach bumped me up pretty much 100 grams
of fat so earlier I had the first time
ever having 93 7 ground beef or as the
always the other way around yours have
97 3. it's at 93 7 and I had an egg with
the yolk so like I can feel my body like
coming alive a little bit because I have
I have the fats to actually
um because you know your emotions and
your feelings are off your hormones your
hormones are off of fats I actually have
enough fats to feel whereas the last two
three weeks I don't even I can't
biologically feel even if I wanted to I
just don't have it to feel you know
to feel what like sad feelings happy
like anything you're just numb
yeah it's like you need eyes to see
right so you need hormones to feel like
if someone cut the top part of your head
and they cut that off and then they like
let's say the part that has like the
love part of your brain they can
literally cut that part out and it'll be
a psychopath
so you need fats and hormones to feel if
I don't have fats how can I feel so I
just couldn't feel the last like week or
two it's been it's been it's been and
that's also the wills to survive that's
also a feeling right you want to survive
you want to win it was like that was
like the first time I was like [__] like
my cardio is actually really good
because I'll do cardio for a very
extended periods of time
and I'm not huffing and puffing like I
went on a five mile walk with my mom and
she was dying and she's actually really
good at walking and I didn't even really
like
break a sweat but then my will to want
to walk was like I don't even want to do
this or anything that's in the
discipline kicks in yeah the last five
days has been [__] insane what do you
think it's gonna be like coming back to
normal once your show's wrapped that's
what I'm so scared of I'm actually
extremely scared because you know I'm a
I'm a raccoon Dicker right I [__]
love to like that's our own like CUNY
little term of like kind of like YOLO
live life so I like
dope [__] you know if we're in if we
randomly travel I'm like give me the
craziest [__] oh [__] this [__]
restaurant got this triple quadruple
stack French toast made out of Pancakes
that stacked you know give me that so I
already have that in my personality type
so what I'm scared of is I swung this
hard this way and then now I swing all
the way back
and then possibly even further you know
because usually you swing harder the
other way I don't want to get to 240
250. I want to be able to go you know
what I was able to get below 10 body fat
now swing to a good balance and maintain
like 11 or 12 just year round and then
enter into my 40s with like a nice
little alley oop you know and then that
could be good
what um what parameters are you putting
into place for all of that
um like immediately after your show
what's the plan because that's its own
phase right because you're so depleted
you have to get back to just Baseline
yeah so
um I'm really putting my hands in or
putting my like life in the hands of my
coach shout out to Jared feather
nutrition coach yeah Jed feather is my
nutrition coach and I'm really putting
my my destiny in his hands he's an ifbb
Pro he's done it forever he's an ifbb
Pro not only is he a coach he's a
coach's coach so he actually coaches
other coaches he did me a big favor by
taking me on as a client he rarely takes
on athletes usually takes on coaches
and um
he's helping me with everything and so
he knows what my goals are
so whatever he teaches me to help swing
back the other way I'm just gonna follow
it
um because it's it took so much will and
time and sacrifice and even from you
from taika to get to where I am now
I don't want to like fumble the ball I
don't want to Fumble the three-pointer
on the game-winning shot you know
can we see what you look like right now
um at two weeks out after I just ate
yeah what is it gonna be a huge
difference to me it is I mean now I have
like that kind of bodybuilding like oh
this is my good stuff if you're
listening you definitely want to watch
the video
okay whoa too low
oh I've never so I've never had AB veins
before and I actually have ad veins yeah
it's pretty cool
yeah
but if you go on my Instagram you'll see
a ton of like me like ripped after a
workout and stuff like that but yeah why
were you pulling your shorts solo what
the [__] I'm trying to show my advice I
didn't I forgot where they were
because I've never had that before you
know your whole life so that that was
like super cool to go oh [__] like when
once you start the two main things is
ADD veins and glue striations that's
when you're like are you getting those I
don't have glute striations you think
because your ass is too fat
it's funny
um I've been trying to be funny you do
have a fat ass we all know and it sounds
like a rap lyric
um
uh I think I to actually be like Pro
level I think I got this is probably a
good amateur good first time to get Pro
level you need to get glue striations
how does that happen so if like let's
say I was trying to really get my Pro
card on the first try I would probably
be dieting from now for another four to
like eight weeks
[__] crazy right yeah that is crazy I
know someone that's doing it right now
they just she just did a show and then
she's like that this doesn't matter like
obviously it matters but she's like I'm
still gonna continue to die and do a
next show they want to they want to get
it yeah they want to really get their
Pro card so they're just gonna push it
even how crazy this is the last question
because we gotta wrap it up but
what is so this is from a male
perspective Right male biology because
female male biology completely different
yeah
um for a female to do it
what are her side effects
truly or yes naturally for now
um because I have heard that like they
will lose their period and like a bunch
of [__] happens to them too I think
that's when you it's important to have a
really good coach because you're going
to manage your hormonal response and you
guys have the menstruation cycle so
that's something to be extra aware of
that you're probably gonna need to do
certain things because you guys are
gonna naturally bloat we do that was
something I had to look I had to pay
attention to when I competed because I I
was lucky enough that I didn't have to
compete in powerlifting that I didn't
have to ever cut weight yeah because I'm
usually around the same weight
um but when it came to my period time
like before I started I would gain an
easy 10 to 15 pounds well yeah just from
probably water or whatever yeah whatever
the hell's going on everybody so yeah
you're gonna blow so that's tough
um you also have a spike in hormones
that is outside of your guys's control I
don't know how that gets expressed
physically but I'm sure it does
something
so there's a couple things you guys have
to manage but then from what I
understand if you have a good coach
they'll talk to you and you wouldn't
lose your period but it's common though
it's a common thing because you know
once your hormones drop
then but yeah because their fats are
literally right at the point where
that's anything lower than that and like
you said your hair falls out the nails
get all brittle and ultimately when
you're doing these things what's the
goal right the goal is to win
so if the goal is to win then some
people are like well [__] my period you
know [__] my hair [__] my nails I'm
trying to win yeah so
um that's that's like your your North
Star is different you know yeah when
you're during maintenance you're
probably like I want to be healthy you
know Omega-3s you eat some fish oil yeah
almonds or whatever and this also feels
like it's like a long-term thing right
like it's super rare for someone to just
super rare for someone to just say hey
I'm going to do bodybuilding and then
become a pro right away
um so yeah this is it seems like it's a
long-term like lifestyle shift and a lot
of the professional bodybuilders that I
know of
um they make they're like in their 50s
60s still maintaining the same thing
obviously not as extreme but for sure
like they still look pretty [__] fit
for the average person yeah that's the
thing that I learned a lot about not
just this but also being in Jiu Jitsu
class and then even that dance video I
was watching the other day where it's
like an advanced dance class I was like
man people that are successful
really love the journey you love the
journey and then the results are a
result of your journey not the other way
around the people that swing back the
other way hard that like did their first
power lifting me and they never
powerlifted again or they do their first
Jiu Jitsu never Jiu Jitsu again or got
ripped and now like three years later
they found out they're fat it's they've
never found a way to fall in love with
the journey it's only with the result
and then once you get the result you're
not going to care you're done yeah yeah
so like that loving the journey is like
and by the journey it's more so just
loving the learning and the lessons and
all that and the day-to-day grind I
think actually loving doing it every
single day and having that day-to-day
grind produces those results you know
yeah
um I know I said I had the last question
but there's one more right now that
you're kind of not at your lowest but
you're pretty low because I feel like
the week of the show you're gonna be at
your [__] lowest
Lois what of everything Morel like
energy mental state all of that I
actually think I'm going to start
feeling pretty good
oh really like this meal I had this
morning I can feel like all the fats
like like I actually like I was actually
worried yesterday right and we're
planning to do the podcast today I was
like [__] man I don't even know how I'm
gonna stay up because there's there's a
point in time where I would down a whole
pre-workout and then down another like
drinking workout in there no no I've got
a whole pre-workout down a like a
straight up another energy drink and I
just you're doing that and I just felt
normal I felt like I could sleep right
after that's how low I was
and um this morning I after I had my
food with all that high fats like I
actually feel like
I'm responding and I could actually like
feel like I could feel myself coming
alive and I have two more days of this
so I do have one more day of depletion
but that's just one day right before the
show and then even the two days is it a
24 hour
yeah and then even the day before that
though I get to have [__] like 10
rice cakes with peanut butter and all
that so I think like I'll be prepared to
have that depletion so I think from now
until then I think I'm actually gonna
feel like
happy and feel like normal which is
pretty pretty good uh okay so my
question then would be do you foresee
yourself doing this ever again
I always say no
I don't think so
um
just because I feel like it's like a one
and done thing but you never know you
know I feel like you always go like damn
I did that but what if
so like I I might go to a point where I
get you know healthy balance maybe 12
body fat now and I might look back at
maybe some of my show photos and go
damn what if I got down to six or five
percent or whatever you know but right
now I just think like
I have so many other goals that I want
to accomplish yeah this isn't up there
it's not up there and
um it's also not one of those things
that fit nicely into what you want to do
yeah like bodybuilding I've learned it's
truly a 24 7 lifestyle like you train
for that hour or two with barbellism
waste yes and then you have to diet the
whole day which you have the like you
have to I'm literally eating dinner at
nine so I can eat and then go right to
sleep you know and then on top of that
the other thing that people don't talk
about is how much
um activity you have to have during the
day AKA your steps so I have to keep
like I don't even talk to you in taika
anymore you know in order to sitting
there if we are talking about something
I'm just moving I'm this distracting guy
that's just constantly moving I'm at the
supermarket I see a line I just start
moving because I have to hit 20 000
steps a day and for those of you guys
who don't know how much that is one mile
is 2 000 steps so I'm doing 10 miles on
my feet for like the last
two weeks so that's almost like I think
I did the calculation
that's 10 marathons I did in 14 days
that's on my feet isn't that crazy yeah
so that's the part of bodybuilding
people don't really talk about I did 10
marathons technically
and that's just one aspect of
bodybuilding so like I would say if
people ask me like what's the hardest
thing you've done so far I think
bodybuilding is a way above marathon
training
um because because I'm such an eater
it's so easy to train my [__] ass off
give it to me one hour two hours three
hours you could eat but if I can go get
some [__] fettuccine alfredo I'll be
back tomorrow [__] you know but
with this you can't you train your
[__] ass off and then you're eating
like [__] two carrots in the [__]
almond or whatever I'm like and then but
I'm the toughest [__] in the
world oh yeah let's drag that out for
like 10 12 16 weeks and see if you still
have that spark like once you're [__]
suffocating you know like 12 weeks in
versus on week one
well damn good for you for sticking it
up thank you
any last thoughts no
any sponsors yes uh thank you guys for
watching and this entire bodybuilding
series is gonna be on the barbell
Brigade YouTube It's the stuff it's a
stud muffin series I'm doing it with JP
and as of recent we just dropped our
brand new Wrecking Crew collection which
is perfectly in time with this because I
needed it like I actually like some days
I would go train and I just felt like
[__] lazy piece of [__] and I would
put on The Wrecking Crew I'm like dude I
came in a [__] wreck it what the [__]
am I doing stop being a little [__]
should I put it on and actually
motivated me I'm like [__] yeah so go
check that out Wrecking Crew collection
just drop the bottlebrigade.com check
out the whole series on bottle Brigade
stud muffins see you guys next time bye